[Music]
justin's in raleigh hey justin welcome
to the ramsay show
how you doing mr ramsay
good better not deserve how can we help
all right so
um i just kind of stumbled across your
teachings i haven't really dived into it
yet but i am in 90 000 worth of you know
overall cumulative debt debt and uh i'm
just kind of like at a loss of like
should i stop bankruptcy
what should i do especially when i have
um
like garnishments coming against me or
starting to come against me so
scary times sir
yes sir
so uh what do you make what's your
household income are you married
uh no sir single okay what do you make
i make about um
40 000 a year okay what are the
garnishments
on uh garnishment is on it's a old
credit card debt it's like five thousand
dollars total on that one
did they tell you they were gonna
garnish it or they actually turned it
into your employer
uh they actually so i had a
um
garnishment
hearing today okay so okay
they're really doing it okay and um what
other what other kind of debts are in
the 90
all right so um i do have seventy
thousand dollars student loans
uh
i have about
ten thousand dollars
collectively with you know just credit
card debt um
eight thousand dollars just medical
bills and
other like unsecured debt and you're
working 40 hours
well i'm working
right now i'm working about 50 60 so i'm
taking all the overtime i can get really
that leaves you at 40 000 income
no no i just started this new job i was
a teacher beforehand okay so with you
working on this ot what are you going to
be making
uh i expect to make about between 50 55
when it's all said and done well here's
the bad news is you're not bankrupt
here's the good news is you're not
bankrupt student loans are not bank
reputable
right
so you wouldn't file bankruptcy on
twenty thousand bucks man
you go to work and work on a plan and
work your way through this you got to
beat this garnishment off with a
settlement offer of some kind have you
got any money at all
um i mean
not on hand i could probably liquidate i
do have like 500 in
a like stock portfolio from robinhood
that i can liquidate and do
let's start gathering some money
together and try to offer the people
that are garnishing you about 20 cents
on the dollar if you can
which on five thousand bucks that'd be a
thousand dollars right and see if you
can get a settlement going with them to
settle this don't offer it as a payment
it's a settlement in full
uh here's what we're gonna do i've been
where you are i'm i've been scared like
you are i know how it feels and i'm not
going to leave you hanging with a short
radio answer i'm going to put you into
ramsey plus to go through financial
peace university i'm going to pay for it
and kelly's going to hook you up with
one of our financial coaches and help
you walk your way through this so you
don't file bankruptcy no charge we're
not going to charge you a dime you're
not bankrupt you're just scared and
don't know your way out and we'll show
you how